you never really know what the arc of
your character is going to be when you
start getting scripts
but both of you guys this season have
really juicy roles
you were given so much to work with uh
what was it like for you finding out
like what your arc was gonna be
on season two i was pretty excited um
oh i had a chat with the guys i was in
australia
and they wanted to talk to me about
basically the entry into when you first
see gordon
and what that would be um
i i left at the opportunity of doing
something that i'd never done before
but i think i feel like the first season
was like that as well like
those guys sort of you know were writing
as we were
as we were doing it so they they got
time to sort of get to know
us and what they thought we could bring
to the
to the characters and then it sort of
started happening organically i guess
they had their plot points but then
man they gave us some room to play um
like you said just such a
beautiful opportunity to work with a
great team and with such juicy
characters
to be honest i i wasn't given a really
um from the outset detail
yeah arc of what would happen this
season
uh only that we got some fun stuff
planned for you kind of
kind of thing um so i really didn't i
really didn't i didn't know what to
expect
um but i
but i had fun doing it
completely um what uh i am curious
be behind the scenes on a show like this
um
can you can you sort of maybe is there
anything that surpri
would surprise fans of the series to
like learn
or can you sort of talk about the way it
is making this show maybe as compared to
other things you've worked on
how what's it like for you sir like for
me it's the same stuff like
essentially you're dealing with a human
with emotions
and then you've got a whole bunch of
other you know characters that are
coming along with their own emotions and
you put each other together
um and then it becomes about sort of
onset you know compatibility and then
how you get along with everyone that's
on the floor to be honest for me the the
greatest difference in this one
was getting shut down in march
and then waiting you know six seven
months for us to go
back uh into something where we're sort
of building building building building
you're about to hit
sort of the peak of the storytelling
and then having like a seven month break
and then coming back in straight to the
to the pinnacle um i found that
difficult to sort of match and also the
fact that you couldn't sort of just
freely talk to everyone like on set you
had your little
spot and you couldn't sort of you know
the
the the contact or the you know
personable
sort of aspect to storytelling was lost
in a sense and it was sort of
we were isolated and that that was
different from anything that i'd ever
worked on but other than that
um storytelling's generally the same
yeah i i i agree really um
um i think i think yeah it
it was michael and i sort of
i feel like we had a unique position too
because i feel like when we
when the you know when we had to
go in when the production had to shut
down
um like michael said we were hitting
sort of a peak moment
for both of our characters that
wasn't gonna stop it was just gonna
ramp up um so
you know you get into a flow you have a
momentum you've got the ideas
it's all brewing then everything goes
away
and then you have to jump back into it
to find what that is
uh that was challenging i'm i'm with
michael all the way on that that was
that was new i mean we certainly did it
to the best of our abilities
yeah you i mean you've seen roll the
dice i don't know
uh but yeah
oh i was just going to say that i've
seen episodes uh in the later half of
the season so i think i know what you're
talking about
sure right yeah you know i'll say it
like that
so there's a lot of great story lines in
season two
uh besides your own what's your favorite
storyline
uh obviously beside you
i can't talk about my favorite storyline
really um yeah
i'm very curious i wanna i wanna know
now
right um yeah i gotta be honest with you
i
really loved watching michael's stuff
i really really i knew
what he had to deal with i knew what he
dedicated to this season
[Music]
and he pulled it off with flying colors
and and i saw it
um got and there were some moments too
my i
left there were some moments between
jimmy
the younger of the two brothers and you
that were just
brilliant i don't want to give away what
that is but there were just a nugget
i was laughing out loud and i replayed
it a few times and i was like
this is incredible this is awesome um
so yeah so i would um i would say that
that
you know knowing what what dedication
michael put in to the second season i
was really curious how it
uh transpired how it came out
um and i don't think a damn person is
going to be disappointed by it
yeah i definitely agree michael you did
i think actually both of you did such
great work in this season and
really i would really love to talk about
specifics but obviously
you know yeah it's tricky isn't it but
yeah same
i i uh i had a similar
um experience to jonesy not looking at
my work but looking at jonesy looking at
your stuff
it's it's really solid work um second
season we
geez we got some opportunities and and
it was so good to see
jonesy take hers really shining so
excited for people to see
what um what everyone's cooked up for
the second run
definitely i'm going to say congrats
with the show getting a season three i
obviously don't know what happens in
nine and ten i don't know if you guys
make it or not i mean i have no idea but
um
when what season do you think it's gonna
be where they introduce a starship
[Laughter]
yeah totally it's a good question it's
definitely a wrong question
yeah i just never know what those guys
are going to do
even at the start before before season
one like
we didn't get a really clear picture of
what was going to come out the scripts
are sort of coming out as we're shooting
them
um and it was the same with this one as
well you've got an idea like i had an
entry point they said
look this is going to be you when we
first see you
and then away we're going to go from
there so for me it was about trying to
get myself sort i had about six weeks to
get
match ready um for the you know the way
that we first see gordo
and so just sort of ran at that and then
on we went with the with the season and
i'm guessing it's going to be the same
with three as well you sort of get an
entry point
it's like uh you know they'll give you
the door and then
away you go um on that note i gotta stop
i'm just gonna say sincerely i'm a huge
fan of the show you guys did such great
work
um good luck with the rest of the
interviews
thanks a lot thank you